I'm very nervous I'm worried I'm white
today we're going to be taking a DNA
test finally to find out if I'm 100%
Puerto Rican no such thing as 100%
Puerto Rican move on huh what what
happened there's no such thing as 100%
Puerto Rican Puerto Rican or Puerto Rico
is just another bust up in uh slavery
land if I take a DNA test my DNA is not
going to say 100% Haiti it's not I
wonder if M would say 100% like
subsaharan Africa most of it
probably what I'm looking at your DNA
test what do you mean your
forehead facts I'm actually curious
because like I think the difference
between you and I is that you come from
a slave Colony like you know originally
your your ancestors and you come from
aing country that never been Colin right
but there's also been a lot of trade for
countries maybe once like for 10 years
so the question would be like I wonder
what that would look like but I'm just
not comfortable doing a DNA test because
I don't want to my DNA to who are
allowed to resell them and do whatever
they want with them cuz I think remember
hearing about the FBI using one of these
things and gaining access to somebody's
DNA through I really hope that I get
full 100% Mexican 100% Mexican if I
don't get 100% Mexican I'm going to be
sad I'm from the Dr and Sri Lanka so
like there's some black in there but my
mom's last name is very white so
something weird probably happened there
I hope that I'm uh B Bunny's cousin
imagine I want know like how much like
indigenous I have that's like the main
thing I want to know so first thing
let's open these spit into the funnel
until the amount of liquid saliva
reaches the that's so much it depends
for who yeah but generally we like it
for DNA
purposes oh oh hell no to what line I
don't know if I have that much in me you
know Ready Set
spit
I like how you I'm classy you're not
you're still spinning baby you're still
spinning on scam yeah if if you suck but
you cover your mouth you're
sucking okay that's it so now we have to
close
this now we're going to ship it and we
wait I think 3 to 5 weeks imagine
there's just some [__] creep
somewhere out there being
like like technically they only need a
small amount of the DNA but this guy's
just like going to put this in there and
there and there a bit for me all right
next
one I was definitely some creepy dude
who wanted to get like an only fans girl
saliva i' be like hey I work for a jean
company just send us a tube of your and
I can get it for you for free you don't
you want to know where you're from as
soon as that [__] gets you like
exclusive only fans
content okay so it's been about four or
five weeks we finally got the results
I'm super scared nervous I'm excited I
don't know I'm anxious I don't know what
what I am having an identity
crisis you're going to be very European
yes you're going to be very European
yeah D is going to say white y I'm very
nervous I'm worried I'm white you're
worried you're white but it's just funny
seeing these people like terrified about
the idea that they might have any
percentage Yeah it's like you might be
if if you're Asian you might have gang
is Kang on you it's okay cuz
[__] was and also just peep it
like yo do you think anybody comfortably
out here like I'm terrified I might have
some black in me it's like okay I mean
some people are terrified yeah but they
can't say that [__] publicly what we do
what we do oh my gosh I'm 71.9% European
hey yeah we can tell yeah we we can
tell Spanish and Portuguese
69.8 0.33% Italian no wonder I like
pasta so much why is this like the most
broadly bro like white DNA cuz you're
white what he
said but bro blank canvas what do you
what do you mean you how is it just so
white tuna casserole Bruh Bruh Bruh you
look cottage cheese 71% feta cheese I
mean all the white cheeses I mean you
look if you literally took yourself and
went to most places in Europe they would
think you're from them I'm very white D
ashkani Jewish 0.8 3.2% conges and
southern east African let's go to the
Congo going no no no they're not
claiming you they got problems I'm
honestly very very surprised at the fact
that I have more indigenous American
blood than African blood oh I number I
don't like which 44% European okay I can
see it I I was expecting more 46.9% East
Asian indigenous American okay okay okay
I got the native roots you know I'm very
to touch 1% Jewish what's up where's
Mexico there you go it even tells you
like what part of Mexico I'm from that's
wild Leon halisco halis is known for
like a little bit more wide a little bit
like colored eyes
blonde hair so that's super interesting
Chihuahua you already know baby that's
where I'm
from 915 0.4% Italian I think that's why
I dress so well if you say so oh my God
I'm not white like at all oh thank God
I'm mostly Central and South Asian
Southern Asian 45% we knew that southern
Indian and Sri Lankan
45.5% chocker the other
36% is subsaharan African are we
surprised no oh no European 10% that is
an amount I can
allow it is wild how these people do not
want to be any percentage white how
terrify some and I think I think because
this is like a a buzzfeed knockoff pedal
like I'm pretty sure that's what it is
it's like these guys their ideology is
always about critiquing whiteness and
whiteness is always bad that they would
even shame themselves if they came to
find out or they would hate themselves a
little bit more cuz they've been so busy
hating white people for no good reason
sometimes this corny it's fine got to be
European than
you oh my gosh I am
88.7% European yes yes yes yes yes your
lips European yes your hair your skin
tone European it's okay it just is what
it is it's cool it's all right people
look at my forehead they're like 95%
East Africa I'm like yeah I won't be
like like I look like it
98 listen you don't have to agree so
aggressively wow okay I already said it
I I put myself just put in that box and
you're like let me close the lid I
didn't ask for your help maybe maybe the
need the lid needs to be shut like calm
down it's like I'm agreeing with you I
don't I never met someone so pissed that
I agree with them because I didn't ask
you to agree oh is that what it
is because I think I don't look good it
doesn't mean that you need to go and say
I never said you don't look good you
don't but I never said
that
why you
B you're disrespectful you know that
you're disrespectful yeah you are and I
think you know you're disrespectful too
yo pop them veins on your for back calm
down calm down why why you so bad yo
listen careful you building up that bad
karma why you why you mad when I agree
with you this is how hurricanes happen
oh my God I just it's butterfly fight I
just agree with you do a bit of talking
[__] and then all of a sudden people
back home got to get blown away it is it
is it is it's not calm down it is stop
being stop being like that have you seen
the comments you really think that
[__] think you ugly have you
seen the comments out there it don't
matter what they think it's how I think
and you agree with how I think and
that's unacceptable I can't agree with
you no what huh listen All That Matters
all that matters is like you make no if
I say critique as myself you don't have
to just agree aggressively and fast like
you didn't PA you be like I'm a yay are
whoa I never said that I said you are
ugly but I mean I never said that
I also said I never said that and you
have a big ass forhead see this is why
men are insecure cuz we have friends
like this in our life
friends
85.4% so no Italian no Italian
interesting I'm going to call my mom
about this and what's the first state in
Mexico that pops up Mexico you
Mexico because you know that's a place
where white people are but you you you
don't understand that you're white true
that but if it was white from alisco
then it's okay but if it's white white
there it's no okay no wayo if it's white
European noo but if it's white halisco a
little bit of salsa in there a little
bit of spices so that's good that's
weird yeah please okay be report we
don't want to kick you off from the team
40% 40.9% East Asian and Indigenous I
wanted 70 or 80 you're 4% less colonized
and I
congratulations oh my God yo throw your
phone all right from Spanish and
Portuguese 27% welcome to the team
Northwestern European British I can see
that the class the Elegance that you
carry yourself with it is so funny that
they hear English and they're like oh
the Elegance the [__] it's white it's
like bro it's white with an accent These
Guys these guys always talk about like
racism and like colonized but like
you're literally engaging that behavior
so the stereotypes like when you think
of elegant or or or sophisticated people
you think of British first off I've been
to Britain I've been to England godamn
okay there's some of the raunchiest
nastiest most dirty-minded people you
could ever imagine in terms of their
humor it's not because they have a queen
that they s sophisticated listen go go
see the [__] drink there is
nothing sophisticated or classy about a
lot of these people oh [__] off
my I'll spark you in your face
blood from I have what I'm from Chanda
which is number three mine too mine all
of salvad is lit up right now I've never
been to Salvador but I have like a bunch
of departments that were connected to me
they call them departments they don't
call them cities well in we call them
departamentos so not states or cities no
we had an ancestor from Lebanon I don't
see leanon here so somebody like
unfortunately I did not discover that
I'm princess dian's long lost Rel not or
a long lost Royal what surprise you the
most the 44% European oh my gosh like no
offense no offense to Europeans you know
too my vanilla friends out there love
all of you finding out I'm I'm I'm white
no offense to the white people like you
guys are fine I just don't like just
finding I have anything in common with
you disgusts
me I'm not no no offense no offense no
offense to all my black people just
finding I'm part black like it it makes
me really upset something just no
offense nothing wrong with being you
you're
beautiful listen to these people like
I'm 1% 1% Jewish I don't think you can
claim that come on I mean you just say
you're Mexican and I'm Puerto Rican and
that's it don't don't think about it too
much yeah don't think about it too much
cuz we don't like the results so we just
going to pretend like it didn't happen
it's fine it's a legacy of the past it's
our DNA it is what it is accept it
nobody going to fault you for what your
ancestors hundreds of years ago just
move on [__] weirdos anything else no
how upset would you be if you find out
your 10% European I don't give a [__]
man mean nether bro i' be like oh
interesting and I move on with my
dat I wish take you find out if part
lizard that should be fine that should
be